- Check out these pictures.
They look like well-drawn cartoons, right?
Well, it's not a cartoon at all.
It's the face of makeup
artist Annie Thomas,
who's amazing.
She uses a combination of
all sorts of makeup and paper
to create these spectacular images.
Did you check out Annie's
TikTok, did you see it?
- Unbelievable!
- The first time I saw it,
I felt like it was watching Sixth Sense,
it was a trip.
I was like, wait what?
- Like you said, it was like mesmerizing
where I just was like caught myself
with my moth agape and just like.
Oh yeah, I gotta get back
to reality, it's crazy.
So cool, so artistic, so creative.
Well done.
- Yes, I've never seen anything like that.
- So cool.
I love it, I'm gonna go
home and try it on my face.
It'll be terrible.
- I know I will fail, so
I will not even attempt.
Do you do TikTok dances,
speaking of TikTok?
- I've been diving into
some TikTok lately,
but it's funny, I don't
dance a lot on TikTok.
- I was gonna say, because
I see you on TikTok,
but you don't dance a ton.
- No, I just act like an idiot.
- Which I'm into.
- I feel like it's just like a green light
and permission to be like, hey be a dork.
So I love that.
- [Kelly] I feel like that's
how I came into the world.
- [Guest] And my poor
girlfriend, she's just like
- [Kelly] That one's my favorite!
- She's trying to do,
and I'm just being just an absolute.
And it's funny 'cause,
- I just wish I was in my
house looking that cool.
- She's always doing something
and I'm always just behind her,
getting in her face or something.
- [Kelly] That's the best part.
- She just carries on, she
just carries on with her life.
- I love that.